some of the debates I have with myself
about everything from a technology
perspective
is how much to hold on to the tools
you're comfortable with versus how much
to invest in using modern tools and the
signal that the communities provide you
with is the noisy one because a lot of
people year to year get excited about
new tools and you have to make a
prediction are these tools defining a
new generation or something that will
transform programming or is this just a
fad that will pass certainly with
JavaScript Frameworks and front and the
back end of the web there's a lot of
different styles that came and went I
remember learning uh
what was it called the action script I
remember for flash
um you know learning how to program in
Flash uh learning how to design doing
graphic animation all that kind of stuff
in Flash same with Java applets I
remember creating quite a lot of java
applets thinking that this potentially
defines the future of the web and it did
not well you know in most cases like
that the particular technology
eventually gets replaced
but
many of the concepts that the technology
introduced or made accessible first
are preserved of course
because yeah we're not using Java
applets anymore but the notion of
reactive web pages
that sort of contain little bits of code
that respond directly to
something you do like pressing a button
or a link or hovering even
uh is has certainly not gone away
and that those animations that were made
painfully
complicated with flesh
I mean flash was an innovation when it
first came up
and when it was replaced by JavaScript
equivalence
stuff
it was a somewhat better way to do
animations but those animations are
still there not all of them
but but sort of
again there is an evolution and often so
often with technology
the the sort of the technology that was
eventually thrown away or replaced
was still essential to to sort of
get started there wouldn't be jet planes
without propeller planes
I bet you but from a user perspective
yes from the feature set yes but I from
a programmer perspective it feels like
all the time I've spent
with actionscript all the time I spent
with Java on the applet side for the GUI
development I well no Java I have to
push back that was useful that because
it transfers but the Flash doesn't
transfer so some things you learn and
invest time in what yeah what what you
learned this kid this kill you picked up
learning action script yeah
was sort of it was perhaps
a super valuable skill at the time you
picked it up if if you if you learned
action script early enough
but
that skill is no longer
in demand well that's the calculation
you have to make when you're learning
new things like today people start
learning programming today I'm trying to
to see what are the new languages to try
what are the new uh systems to try that
what are the new IDs to try to to keep
keep improving because that's why we
start when we're young right
but that seems very true to me that that
when you're young you have your whole
life ahead of you and your
you're allowed to make mistakes in fact
you should you should feel encouraged to
to do a bit of stupid stuff yeah try not
to get yourself killed or seriously
maimed but try stuff that
deviate from from what everybody else is
doing
and like nine out of ten times you'll
just learn why everybody else is not
doing that or why everybody else is
doing it some other way and one out of
10 times you sort of
you discover something that's better or
that's that somehow works I mean there
are all sorts of crazy things that were
invented
uh by accident by people trying trying
stuff together
that's great advice to try random stuff
make a lot of mistakes once you're
married with kids you're probably going
to uh be a little more risk-averse
because now there's more at stake and
you've already hopefully had some time
where you where you were experimenting
with crazy [ __ ] I like how marriage and
kids solidifies your choice of
programming language how does that the
robber Frost poem with the The Road Less
taken which I think is misinterpreted by
most people but that anyway I I feel
like the choices you make early on
especially if you go all in they're
gonna Define the rest of your life's
trajectory in a way that like you
basically are picking a camp so
um you know there's if you invest a lot
in PHP if you invest a lot in.net if you
invest a lot in JavaScript
you're going to stick there
you that's that's your life Journey
only as far as that technology remains
relevant yes yes I mean if if at age 16
you learn coding in C
and by the time you're 26 C is like a
dead language
then there's still time to switch
there's probably some kind of Survivor
bias or whatever it's called in in sort
of your observation that that you pick a
camp because there are many different
camps to pick and if you pick dot net
then then you can Coast for the rest of
your life because that technology is now
so ubiquitous of course that it's even
if it's if it's bound to die it's going
to take a very long time well for me
personally
I had a very difficult in my own head
Brave leap that I had to take relevant
to our discussion which is most of my
life I programmed in C and C plus plus
and so uh having that hammer everything
looked like a nail
so I would literally even do scripting
in C plus plus like I would create
programs that do script like things and
uh when I first came to Google and and
before then it became already before
tensorflow before all of that there was
a growing realization that c plus is not
the right tool for machine learning we
could talk about why that is it's
unclear why that is a lot of things
has to do with community and culture and
how it emerges and stuff like that but
for me to decide to take the leap to
python like all out basically switched
completely from C plus plus except for
highly performant robotics applications
there were still uh
there's still a culture of C plus plus
in in the space of robotics
that was a big leap
like I had to you know like like people
have like existential crises or midlife
crises or whatever you have to realize
almost like walking away from uh from a
person you love
um because I was sure that c plus would
have to be a lifelong companion for a
lot of problems I would want to solve C
plus would be there and it was a
question to say well that might not be
the case because sibo spots is still one
of the most popular languages in the
world one of the most used one of the
most dependent on it's also still
evolving quite a bit I mean
that that is not a sort of a fossilizing
community yes they they are doing great
Innovative work actually a lot but yet
the sort of their Innovations are hard
to follow if you're not already a
hardcore C plus plus user well this was
the thing it pulls you in it's a rabbit
hole I was a hardcore the all meta
programming template programming like I
I would start using the modern C plus
plus as it developed right not just the
not just the shared pointer and the
garbage collection that makes it easier
for you to work with some of the flaws
but the detail like The Meta programming
the the crazy stuff that's that's coming
out there but then you have to just
empirically look and step back and say
what language am I more productive in
sorry to say what language do I enjoy my
life with more
and uh readability and able to think
through and all that kind of stuff that
those questions are harder to ask when
you already have
a loved one which in my case was C plus
plus and then there's python uh like
that Meme was is the the grass is
greener on the other side am I just
infatuated with a new fad new cool thing
or is this actually going to make my
life better and I think a lot of people
face that kind of decision it was a
difficult decision for me
um when I made it at this time it's an
obvious switch if you're into machine
learning but at that time it wasn't
quite yet so obvious so it was a risk
and you know you have the same kind of
stuff with um
I still because of my connection to
Wordpress
I still do a lot of back-end programming
in PHP uh
and the question is you know node.js
python do you switch to do you switch
back into any of those
programming there's the case for node.js
for me well more and more and more of
the front end it runs in JavaScript
um and fascinating cool stuff is done as
JavaScript maybe use the same
programming language for the back end as
well
uh the case for python for the back end
is well you're doing so much programming
outside of the web in Python so maybe
use Python for the back end and then the
case for PHP well most of the web still
runs in PHP
you have a lot of experience with PHP
why uh fix something that's not broken
those are my own personal struggles but
I think they reflect the struggles of a
lot of people and with different
programming languages with different
problems they're trying to solve it's a
weird one and there there's not a single
answer right because depending on how
much time you have to learn new stuff
where you are in your life what what
you're currently working on who you want
to work with what communities you like
yeah there's not one right choice maybe
if you if you sort of
if you can look back 20 years you can
say well that whole detour through
action script was a waste of time
but
nobody could know that
so you can you can't beat yourself up
over that
uh you just need to accept that not
every choice you make
is going to be perfect maybe sort of
keep Plan B in the back of your mind
uh but don't don't overthink it don't
don't try to sort of don't don't create
a spreadsheet with like where you're
trying to estimate well if I learn this
language I expect to make x million
dollars in a lifetime and if I learn
that language I expect to make why a
million dollars in a lifetime and which
Which is higher and what which has more
risk and where is the chance that it's
like picking picking a stock
kind of kind of but uh
I think with stocks you can do
diversifying your investment as good
with productivity in life
boy that spreadsheet is possible to
construct
like if you actually carefully analyze
what your interest in life are where you
think you can maximally impact the world
there really is better and worse choices
for a programming language that are not
just about the syntax but about the
community about where you predict the
community is headed
what large systems are programmed in
that but can you create that spreadsheet
because that sort of you're mentioning a
whole bunch of inputs that go into that
spreadsheet where you have to estimate
things that are very hard to measure and
even harder I mean they're they're hard
to measure
retroactively and they're even harder to
predict like what is the better
community
well better is is one of those
incredibly difficult words what's better
for you is not better for someone else
no but we're not doing a public speech
about what's better we're doing a
personal spiritual journey I can
determine a circle of friends
circle circle one and circle two and I
can have a bunch of parties with one and
a bunch of parties with two and then
right down or take a mental note of what
made me happier right and that you know
you have if you're a machine learning
person you want to say Okay I want to
build a large company that does that is
grounded in machine learning but also
has a sexy interface that has a large
impact on the world what languages do I
use you look at what Facebook is using
you look at what Twitter is using then
you look at performance more newer
languages like rust or you look at
languages that have taken that most the
community uses in the machine learning
space that's Python and you can like
think through you can hang out and think
through it and it's it's always a invest
and the the level of activity of the
community is also really interesting
like you said C plus plus and python are
super active in terms of the development
of the language itself
but do you think that you can make
objective choices there no no well but
there's a gut you build up like don't
you don't you believe in that gut
feeling everything is very subjective
and yes you most certainly can have a
gut feeling and your gut can also be
wrong that's why there are billions of
people because they're not all right I
mean clearly there are more people
living in the Bay Area who have plans to
sort of create a Google sized company
then there's room in the world for
Google sized companies and they're gonna
have to Duke it out in the market the
space and there's many more choices than
just the programming language